I want my family to know I'm not giving
up the fight give me a chance
all I ask waking up in the middle of the
night in cold sweats going from making a
living to making nothing it's so nice
when people pass you by and with the car
and they're waving or blowing the horn
at you I'm certainly no hero hi I'm
Jessica home it is my sincere
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm Donna Friesen one of the many
things in short supply these days apart
from toilet paper and frozen peas is
humor it's hard to laugh when there's
this invisible virus lurking and there
are all these limits on where we can go
and what we can do and if you are sick
or if you've lost a loved one this is
not a funny time we're going to get into
much of that including the crisis inside
hundreds of care homes we worry for our
families our physical health and our
financial health and that mental health
experts say could create a looming echo
pandemic of mental health issues
it's why Ottawa and the provinces have
launched initiatives to help us cope
with this new reality and that's where
we want to start tonight our well being
and how we can get through this together
because the coronavirus should not put a
stop to our collective sense of humor
more about me I'm training for a 1k
Jessica Holmes has been doing comedy for
a few decades now you should set
achievable goals is what the experts say
and so I'm just I'm not gonna rush it I
just had a baby eight years ago known
for her celebrity impersonations
whether it's a Spice Girl I'm Geri
Halliwell but I don't have to say that
to you because you know I'm very famous
or Celine Dion to everybody in the world
[Music]
she's become famous not only for her
impersonations
but for this confession hi I'm Jessica
Holmes I'm a comedian I've experienced
postpartum depression and regular
run-of-the-mill garden-variety
depression neither was great both socks
she wrote a book about it
depression the comedy a tale of
perseverance running at my meditation
meditation and of my meditation because
I have the world's shortest attentions
and now she like the rest of us is
trying to find the funny side of life in
lockdown and imagining how celebrities
are coping and there's the harsh reality
of personal grooming hey guys I'm coming
to you from the future time travel is
possible you don't need to buy any more
toilet paper
what I wouldn't mind is if someone
picked up a pair of tweezers tweezers
just remember to pick those up and
Jessica Holmes is at her home in Toronto
Jessica you are looking fantastic this
pandemic is really exposed though how we
all really look right how is the
personal grooming going well you know
what I only get out of my onesie once a
week you you go all out
you look fantastic and you were telling
me that you had your kids help with your
look a little bit yeah my kids did my
root color in preparation what we didn't
do was take down our Christmas tree
warranty comedy can be cathartic in dark
times how do you find humor in the midst
of all this anxiety as comedians say
tragedy plus time equals comedy or
stress plus time equals comedy so I have
just learned to always look for the
funny and things to always imagine where
is the laugh track if my life was a
sitcom right now where would the last
track be and that way it kind of takes
the sting out of things and and knowing
also that you know a few months down the
road this will all be punchlines to
late-night jokes and stuff for me life
is just easier that way when you're
looking for it you've been very open to
Jessica about your own depression and
you got through it with therapy and
medication and building healthy habits
how are you handling life right now in
this weird normal and what would you say
to other people who also have gone
through depression how they should
handle the moment we're in absolutely
to anyone who is feeling triggered by
what's happening now I'm so sorry we
will get through this a year from now
life will be calm again
it is triggering the social isolation of
it is triggering not having our regular
routine so I would just say to people
hang on I promise things are going to
get better we're gonna feel better as we
get more and more used to this way of
life what's the funniest thing you find
or have heard about this surreal
situation that we're all in I've loved
seeing how families are reacting to
what's going on and my favorite was this
viral video that came out of England of
a family taking on the characters of
Lynn is the fact was you could see that
they had rehearsed it all day and even
the youngest kids had their parts to
play so I think it is a unifying
experience right now for people who find
themselves at home with nowhere to go
there's a lot of boredom and you know we
can only watch so much Netflix is
boredom a breeding ground for humor
Donna it is absolutely a breeding ground
for that and within two days of the
isolation happening I had my eyebrow
pencil out and was drawn on a tiger king
sort of beard and mustache and that has
been my life just dressing up as
characters different days or trying to
find out what are other comedians online
doing for me it's so beautiful to see
how we come together through comedy how
regardless of how people feel
politically and so on that this kind of
brings us together we're all in it
together and comedy can break the
tension beautifully
[Music]
there's a word being used a lot these
days
hero doctors and nurses and hospital
staff are heroes but there's a whole
range of other people getting the
acclaim they deserve from care workers
to cleaners and grocery store staff and
delivery drivers there are about a
hundred and eighty thousand truckers on
the roads carrying food and other
essentials if they are indeed heroes we
haven't always treated them that way
sometimes doing things like denying them
access to bathrooms
Lyoness Woodstock is from Gatineau
Quebec for work he's a trucker but in
his heart he's a husband father and
grandfather and he's a gospel singer
with a lot of faith the music is
certainly something to go to at a time
like this I don't think there's anything
better
much
[Music]
a month ago nobody was calling us a hero
we were a necessary evil we were stuck
in their way
we were slowing them down on the 401 now
they're like oh yeah you you go first
so it's great some people are calling us
heroes I don't see it that way quite
honestly I'm I'm thankful to be able to
make a paycheck but I feel quite lucky
when somebody says oh you're such a hero
like I know the heroes are the doctors
and the nurses in the emergency room I
don't put myself in harm's way that I
know of they do so as truck drivers
we're not heroes I'm really glad that
what we do helps the economy it's a very
important part and that's exciting it's
great it makes you feel good but we I
don't think any of us wear a cape let me
put it that way well I started off in
Malorie town Ontario cross the border
went down to Baldwinsville New York
unloaded a load there
went over to Liverpool New York just
outside of Syracuse picked a load up
there headed for Fort Erie cross the
border and now here we are in
Mississauga I'll drop this trailer here
tonight grab an empty trailer and head
off to Kingston and basically do the
same thing again tomorrow but there are
some places I don't feel comfortable
going to anymore
down in that New Jersey Jersey City New
York City area I want nothing to do with
that area
I've been running out to Michigan
Pennsylvania Ohio those places don't
bother me too much
it's more rural areas that I've been
running into and there's less people so
less contact I'm pretty self-contained
in the truck here I have my own fridge
and my own food and my own coffee pot
and my own bed and TV so I don't really
need to associate very much with people
except to exchange paperwork it's a
changing world you know you're trying to
sanitize yourself before you go in the
house and take my clothes off in the
laundry room and put them in the washing
machine and the dirty clothes that I
have for the week and smile then she
turns the wash machine on I go to the
shower and then we spend the weekend
pretty much sitting 4 or 6 feet apart
all weekend so it's certainly different
do we have very best to keep the Coleman
19 virus out of our house while we still
get to work and do the job of being a
truck driver we will never go back to
the way things were
I don't believe it'll be a new normal
this is just as important as the
sanitizing we do when we arrive back on
I'm not really sure what the future
holds I do know it's going to be a very
different Canada a very different world
I have faith I have a lot of faith and I
know that we will get through it at
least some of us will
[Music]
why is
is this some sort of joy
[Music]
to
[Applause]
[Music]
it's still hard to believe we've been
thrust into this life-and-death moment
and easy to think it's only older people
who are really at risk for the most part
that is true but there are exceptions
Matt green shields from Okotoks Alberta
is one of them he's 19 years old and
he's just come through the fight of his
life he is one of the youngest people in
Canada to survive kovat 19 and he wants
other young people to pay attention Matt
hi there I'm so glad you're feeling well
enough to talk to us yeah a healthy 19
year old ear you started out that way at
least give us a bit of a timeline you
started feeling sick in mid-march how
quickly did it deteriorate yeah so I
started feeling very mildly sick on the
12th and then I came home to focus at
the time I was living on campus at
University of Calgary and then over the
course of being at home I felt like all
my symptoms had gone away about eight
days later and then on March 24th so 12
days later they all came back at one and
then I was admitted into the hospital on
25th told I had kovat on the 26th and
then told I had mono um at 27 and it was
the combination the doctors say that
made you so sick and and you ended up in
intensive care
describe how you felt at that point well
physically I was not doing so well I was
in pretty rough shape because I was so
sick but mentally knowing that I was
going into the intensive there was
really hard to hear
I remember the doctors coming in and
they they're telling me we're gonna put
you in intensive care for a potential
tracheotomy and I remember just not
saying anything I was just in total
shock because you know you hear stories
about the ICU and what happens and you
never expect your own yourself to be in
there so it was terrifying and I guess
at that point you were also isolated
from your family right they had to stay
away from you what was that like for you
and and for your mom especially yeah I
was with my mom at the time in the
hospital when they told me that the
kovin swab came back positive and I was
actually asleep and so my mom had to
wake me up and break the news that she
had to leave in five minutes and so it
kind of it was that was definitely the
hardest point mentally for me just
knowing that I couldn't see anyone that
I knew in probably the scariest part of
my whole life and
yeah you know just like and the nurses
do I like I give my heart up the nurse
who had to give that news you know it's
just as hard for her to see that happen
as it is for us to take it and yeah it
was it was really tough
so for people who were your age give us
a real clear sense of how you were
feeling what this did to you how you
felt that night when you were in ICU
when I was in ICU I had never felt those
scared and so physically ill in my whole
life and I had never expected at all
like my dawn CIL's and everything was
swollen to the point where I couldn't
communicate I couldn't breathe properly
and I couldn't swallow and so those
three things alone are enough to scare
like they were it was terrifying for me
and being so yeah and you know I never
expected to be in that sort of a spot
where I would need to be in intensive
care and so I guess it's a good thing
way to know that this really did happen
to anyone do you have any idea where you
caught Kovac 19 that's a question that I
would like to know as well I don't have
any ideas but being at university and
living on campus it's such a diverse an
international place that I must have
just touched the wrong doorknob or
something just a free free thing that
I'd never expected you know you decided
to go public with your story I know what
what is it you want young people to know
about this virus yeah at first I didn't
want to go public just given how graphic
my own face was but then I was aware of
some people who were having small house
parties and gathering still like around
people that I know and and you know it's
just it's tough for me to see that
knowing what I went through and I don't
want anyone else to have to go through
that so I decided to come out publicly
with what happened to me to hopefully
raise awareness more of my peers and say
you know I don't know how I got it and
it could really happen to anyone did you
think at one point you might not make it
Matt yeah when I was being wheeled down
the ICU I was definitely starting to
finally question myself it's up at that
point I was thinking you know I'm just
gonna get over it it's just a sickness
like I'm young I'm healthy
but being wheeled down to the ICU and
being in those remote Hall
where there's nobody I was with my
thoughts and I was thinking you know
this is kind of like this is scary now
and then while I was in ICU and all of
my symptoms just exploded and peeked and
how much care I was being given I was
finally thinking like you know I don't
know how this is going to turn out I
don't know how this is gonna end up so
that was definitely a very scary moment
for me to think that Matt you're looking
great now you're talking to us what's
your prognosis how are you doing I'm
doing much better now I've had a lot of
time to recover at home now
I've just been basically sleeping away
the days and trying to get better as
much as I can but yeah definitely better
than it was still ahead from mission
critical 80% of these food businesses
might not survive the crisis to a
critical mission these people are heroes
anything we can do to make their life
easier the new initiative feeding our
health care workers plus a powerful
message to covet 19 get the hell over
the way the side effect Co bid 19 is
having on people waiting for transplants
and up next I went for 3 weeks thinking
my father was fine he's not inside
long-term care homes I think this is a
massive wake-up call the warning signs
ignored and rethinking the value we
place on caring for our elders
I know some of you are watching
anxiously waiting for news desperate to
hear that your mother or father or
husband or wife still alive in their
long term care home you're not allowed
to visit even phone calls are of limited
use especially if your loved one is
nonverbal or has dementia I get it my
parents spent their final days in a care
home and as harsh as it sounds I'm
relieved they passed away before this
pandemic hit because it is inside these
long-term care homes that this
coronavirus is taking hold and taking
lives half the deaths from kovat 19 in
canada are in care homes and in the most
grim cases people are left to die alone
in their beds and it's not like there
were no warnings the families dread the
distance when only want is to be inside
holding a hand all they can do is keep
vigil outside fourth floor fourth when
you're across anything to catch sight of
those dear to them now isolated inside
any precious sign they're okay
like a wildfire the coronavirus has
blazed through Canada's long-term care
homes exposing cracks and faults in the
system from coast to coast to coast
there are now outbreaks in more than 600
facilities accounting for nearly half
the deaths from kovat 19 in Canada
including the very first we
unfortunately have had to death here in
British Columbia it happened here at the
Linn Valley care center in North
Vancouver and it was here too that a
health care worker a woman in her 50s
became Canada's first reported case of
community transmission a troubling sign
the virus had taken hold among our most
vulnerable
public health officials rushed to trace
her contacts and tried to contain the
spread but those who knew best feared
the worst
if you have people in your gathering who
are who are elderly or more
and I just know how stressful it is for
our healthcare system for my colleagues
and for families and then the pattern
began to repeat elsewhere at a small
nursing home in Bobcaygeon Ontario
nearly half the residents died in their
beds and at least 28 staff have tested
positive it's a fantastic community and
to see this happening is heartbreaking
and actually it is heartbreaking soon
there were multiple outbreaks in care
homes across the country most with a
common story a sudden onslaught of cases
sometimes dozens of dead testing and
detection falling woefully behind the
wave caregivers sick and off work those
remaining struggling to keep up in homes
that were often chronically understaffed
before this pandemic residents sharing
rooms and bathrooms staff lacking
personal protective equipment ideal
conditions for a virus to run rampant
those on the frontlines are mostly women
new immigrants and visible minorities
doing difficult deeply personal work for
low pay bathing feeding changing adult
diapers it can be exhausting physically
and emotionally and they often work
part-time in multiple facilities to make
ends meet it remains at a critical low
we really need skilled workers in some
care homes there's been a collapse in
frontline staffing some sick some
staying away because the risk is too
high in my workplace we all drop like
flies you have no idea how fast it
infects everybody it's extremely like
hard for us because you grow attached to
them you don't want to refuse but
obviously a lot of people are gonna feel
unsafe now hundreds of homes are locked
down leaving families worried sick
agonizing at the unthinkable loved ones
left alone in their final hours here I
finally get in my father's on his last
breath literally dead lying in his bed
so I went for three weeks thinking my
father was fine he's not he's dead
and there's the harrowing accounts of
what happened inside Montreal's
residents heron the conditions beyond
words those who were still alive were
dehydrated and malnourished and hadn't
been bathed or changed in days somewhere
along the way there had to be most staff
had left a doctor arrived on the scene
so desperate she called her own husband
and teenage children to come and help
thirty-one residents died in three weeks
the government seized control of the
facility and the premier asked for help
from the military
for a nation it's a defining shameful
moment exposing how we treat our elders
no zany new leggins
our elders he says struggle to leave us
a rich and just society a beautiful
society he says we have a duty to
protect them the fact is our long-term
care system is built on a crumbling
foundation this pandemic has laid bare
long-standing issues that until now
we've chosen to largely ignore doctors
Samir Sinha is an advocate for the needs
of older adults he's director of
geriatrics at Mount Sinai and the
University Health Network hospitals in
Toronto and architect of Ontario's
seniors strategy dr. Sinha first do you
think we have a full and accurate
picture of the scale of outbreaks in
care homes and retirement homes across
the country or have case has been
underreported I don't think we have the
accurate picture that we actually need
right now about how things are
progressing across the country and
that's for a bunch of reasons right now
that some of the ministries for example
have data streams and public health
units have data streams looking at
certain types of homes like nursing
homes but not necessarily retirement
homes so the official numbers that you
see coming out in Ontario really only
include nursing homes but don't actually
include retirement homes that are
equally just as vulnerable and actually
are more numerous than the retirement
homes we have so right now the numbers
you're seeing that really are over a
thousand homes across the country that
are affected don't really give you a
cure accounts and the same issues
happening in the United States and the
problem with this is that if we don't
have the accurate data then you can't
fight a fire blindfolded you know what
is the biggest failing do you think of
our care home system that has allowed
this virus to take hold with such
ferocity I think the biggest issue that
for the country for it at the moment
that's really been the about the way we
stopped our homes so for example many
homes across the country they don't
usually offer nurses and personal
support workers who work in them the
same wage rates that they would get
working in a hospital so it's no
surprise that the majority of homes
across the country tell us that they
actually have trouble recruiting people
to work in the
environments and then they have trouble
actually retaining them because often
when a job opens up at a hospital that
often pays a better wage rate with
benefits like pensions or sick benefits
or sick days for example that people
will jump ship and go there so we have a
real unstable staffing situation you
know the shortage of staff the low pay
the fact staff work in more than one
care home none of that is new all of it
contributed to the spread why weren't
those faults in the system addressed
long ago you know pointing back to the
SARS Commission of 2004 that really
focused on the issue that that staff
working between multiple homes or in
multiple settings was one of the reasons
why stars as a corona virus was
spreading between institutions and
facilities and so it's something that
was recommended way back then that we
actually eliminate that practice and so
former health ministers at the time we
said wait a minute
we made this recommendation back in 2004
why did we never act on it that's a
great question because now we're
actually seeing that while it wasn't
such an issue in the last number of
years because we didn't actually address
that comprehensively people have now
been paying for with their lives
you know I know from firsthand
experience with my own parents that care
home workers are like angels they work
so hard they do incredibly difficult
work they do it with love and patience
why don't we as a society value them
more pay them more and do you think we
will after this I think we have to I
think this is a massive wake-up call
that as we age as a society we're going
to need more homes like these in the
future we should actually treat these
workers I'm not saying better than but
I'm saying at least equal to the way we
actually respect and treat our workers
and hospitals because these workers are
dealing with some of the sickest and
most rayless people in our country and
frankly that when we don't treat them
well we all pay the consequence as a
society and these individuals with their
lives as well you know we've heard from
people who say I want to get my mom or
my dad out of there I'm so worried about
them I can't see them what's your advice
for people should they would you remove
your parent from a care home right now
if I was in BC and Alberta I'd say I
think they're getting things under
control and I think we need to make sure
we can support our homes to support our
loved ones well but I'm nervous about
people who have loved ones in care in
Ontario Quebec right now and for those
families who are thinking well we could
be we could possibly bring our loved
ones home on the Ontario government back
on March 24th actually changed the
regulations to support families to do
this if this is the right decision for
them you've spent your career in the
field of geriatrics looking at aging and
how to help the most vulnerable people
in our society when you look at what's
happening in care homes in so many
places in this country what's your gut
feeling to watch this unfolding it
honestly it's it's it's left me in tears
at times because you know I've dedicated
my life to supporting older Canadians
and enabling them and when I think about
you know 400,000 vulnerable Canadians
across these homes and the fact that we
as a country in many ways have left so
many families and so many individuals
down it tells me that we should have
been doing better and that we can do
better and we have to do better
one of the side effects of this pandemic
is a sharp drop in life-saving organ
transplants transplant centers across
the country have massively scaled back
as hospitals shift priorities to be able
to handle kovat 19 cases living donor
surgeries have largely shut down and
deceased donor transplants are happening
only when the case is urgent sadly that
means many organs are not going to good
use and as Allison Busch Nick explains
those on the waiting list keep waiting
at a distance John Dennis waves to the
love of his life okay penny is living
with dementia her long-term care home
has residents sick with Kovac 19 it's
just too risky to visit for both of them
John has idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
and needs a double lung transplant
Cobin 19 can be a killer especially for
someone with lung disease through covet
19 get the hell on the way to my family
and John's the right guy for a fight I
don't know if they can see that on the
camera an avid adventurer he even
competed in an around-the-world sailing
race he's now in the fight of his life
if all goes well John would travel from
Halifax to the Toronto General Hospital
for transplant this is the largest
transplant program in the country and
one of the top in the world this is a
center of innovation and life-changing
surgeries with the Cova 19 wave coming
on March 13th the hospital announced it
had to scale back transplants heart
liver kidney pancreas and lung delayed
unless a patient is rapidly
deteriorating when we do a transplant we
put patients on anti-rejection pills and
that means really knocking down their
immune system and we're very worried if
we do that to patients and then if they
get Kovac they'll end up with very very
severe manifestations of Kovac that also
means kovat 19 patients and transplant
patients could end up in the same I see
you both needing ventilators spreading
the virus is a concern Colvin seems to
also infect the liver and the kidney and
the heart so so we're we're very
concerned about that
in early March Jim man finally got the
call that he's officially on the
transplant list soon after that another
call about the delays Jim needs a double
lung transplant for severe emphysema
the Koba 19 is what scares me more than
the surgery they've told me if I if I
got
my chance of survival are very very you
feel really let down and it kind of
breaks your heart because we had that
hope and then it's kind of like oh it's
on pause and nobody knows how long this
is gonna go on for so for Jim outgoing
fun-loving and always willing to help a
friend is inside protecting himself
while he waits every time the phone
rings still even though we know it's
closed I still have a little bit of hope
that's what it is and it's not just in
Toronto transplants are on hold or
reduced at centers across the country
leading doctors who refer patients to
worry this does have a huge impact on my
patients but all transplant patients in
general across Canada there's multiple
effects so there's patients right now
who are very unwell and getting sicker
quickly another devastating consequence
of that with programs across the country
scaled back so too is the procurement of
donor organs so essentially those organs
are not used they're lost to the system
which is really another tragedy due to
covert so it's very heartbreaking
actually hundreds of Canadians die every
year waiting for a transplant and now
kovat 19 is making that even tougher the
number of patients on the waitlist is
growing and that will create a backlog
during the last month Toronto General
has performed more than 15 urgent
transplants with safety precautions in
place and testing all donor organs for
kovat 19 all the precautions and gained
knowledge is leading to renewed hope
dr. humar says he's actively working on
how to increase the number of
transplants performed and is optimistic
that can start soon until then Jim and
John are staying safe and hopeful I know
there's there's a fix down the road
it's just hopefully it comes before I
can't want any more like this I know
it's it's getting worse I just hope I
can I can make it to draw that's all I
ask
give me a chance
coming up it's been very hard for her
there's a lot of Tears a lot of
reminiscing grieving in isolation it's
unnatural but it's becoming the new
natural the emotional extremes and
physical distancing taking a toll on
Canadian families
not everyone with the coronavirus get
sick and of those who are sick only a
small percentage die
the infection fatality rate varies
widely it's as high as 13% in Italy and
closer to 3% in Canada but none of that
of course means anything if your loved
one is one of those statistics kovat 19
is so infectious people are often dying
alone and as Ross Lord reports those
left behind are grieving alone three
weeks have passed since the death of
Sophia lesense Keys brother Anthony
their family is unable to grieve
collectively because the threat of kovat
19 has forced her elderly mother Enid
into isolation it's been very hard for
her you know we speak probably two times
a day and stay connected with each other
that way and there's a lot of Tears a
lot of reminiscing the family of Ken
Weiland can relate for two weeks after
he became infected with kovat 19 he was
completely off limits standard policy
aimed at limiting the spread of the
virus worse founded that we couldn't you
know it's like they had taken away my
father and locked him up that was a you
know that was the way I felt about it my
brothers and sisters felt about it in
the end they were finally allowed a
short visit to see their father just
before he passed away the emotional
extremes combined with the constant
stress of life during a pandemic and the
edicts around physical distancing are
taking a toll on Canadians according to
this grief counselor there is definitely
something a phenomenom of survivor's
guilt and guilt in general of not being
able to say goodbye or what what I could
have done differently as the virus
sweeps through long-term care homes
across Canada so does the feeling of
isolation and sorrow that natural
gestures of compassion are forbidden and
you find yourself taking that initial
step forward and then you have to say
whoa and and step back again and it's
it's unnatural but it's becoming the new
natural we for Reverend bill Mercer it's
heartbreaking so life-affirming gestures
are all heroes i baptize you in the name
of the Father and of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit
[Music]
suddenly the choirs in the congregation
are gone leaving only a lonely live
stream however these are different times
and different circumstances in his
province Newfoundland and Labrador most
covered 19 cases have been traced to a
single funeral home gathering funerals
and wakes are banned no more than five
people are permitted at a burial even in
formal processions have been shut down
because people started gathering in
groups on the roadside when I see a
family at the graveside my initial
instinct is to you know either to extend
a hand to say you know I'm sorry for
your loss or you know if you know
someone even on it you know a closer
basis to offer a hug and at this time
we're just not allowed to do that and
and you wrestle with it you struggle
with it and at times you hate yourself
because you're not able to do it it's
not only grieving this restricted
distancing rules are stifling those
once-in-a-lifetime moments like first
time grandparents touching a precious
newborn man when I found out that none
of us could see him none of us could go
in and everything it was just like this
won't be happening this just can't be
happening and they took this over the
car in his kursi plunked him on the
driveway and said okay you can't come
any closer for now they'll get by
watching videos of their grandson nico
emerging into this world those suffering
apart from loved ones who are dying
faced a much more excruciating ordeal if
you're grieving know that you're not
alone we are here for you
Sofia loss in ski is finding ways to
remember her brother
I have Anthony with me right now
these are his gloves and we're holding
each other's hands even
he's not here he's he's with me every
single day she wants desperately for her
entire family to mark her brother's
death and scatter his ashes together
we're gonna hold each other and we're
gonna cry and we're gonna laugh and
we're just going to be shoulder to
shoulder there's no way of knowing when
that will happen as Canada struggles to
withstand this crisis and Canadians
struggle in isolation
still ahead here we go this special
concert series led by Canada's country
Queen and our mission is really really
simple we're trying to save small food
businesses sustaining the line we want
to give our time and our food to the
frontline workers Canadians coming
together to help each other
one of the things that sustains us
through this is food lots of us are
cooking more maybe eating too much but
plenty of restaurants have either closed
or are struggling to survive doing
takeout but everybody's got to eat
including healthcare workers who are run
off their feet
so as Abigail Beeman reports a new
initiative put two and two together to
sustain the line in a flash copepod 19
changed everything for this couple right
on their Toronto restaurants third
anniversary going from earning or making
a living rather to making nothing being
very scared waking up in the middle of
the night in cold sweats but while
figuring out how to pay the bills feed
their children get their laid off staff
hooked up with employment insurance and
launched a delivery service somehow
Veera Sulis and crisp rift is found the
time to think about others in need we
need to get to the hospitals we want to
give our time and our food to feed the
healthcare workers the frontline workers
that's right while facing their own
frightening lis uncertain future the
owners of fat lamb cozinha wanted to
donate to health care workers these
people are heroes you know they need
anything we can do to make their life
easier they couldn't quite figure out
how to do it alone but fortunately a
small team was already cooking up a
solution our mission is really really
simple we're trying to save small food
businesses because 80% of these food
businesses might not survive the crisis
at the same time we're trying to feed
the really deserving frontline
healthcare heroes Aaron Solomon is a
native Montrealer and one of the guys
behind sustain the line the pandemic
initiative pairs restaurants ready to
deliver with people across North America
who want to donate meals to health care
workers donors like lawyer Darlene
Tonelli I really feel for people who
still have to go to work and without
whom none of us could confront ssin when
she heard about sustained the line from
another law firm she encouraged her own
to get on board and they did just a
minute to get out of our own heads and
our own worries and think about other
people I think is what the team
gravitated towards her firm has already
supported two restaurants including fat
Lam cozinha on this day they're dropping
off 30 meals at North York General
Hospital it means a lot to receive meals
like this it nourishes our bodies our
doctors are working 24 hours our
anesthesiologists go to codes they work
in ICU emerge yo are our nurses are
being redeployed our nurses are working
in the recovery room 24 hours as well
Solomon is busy he estimates sustained
the line has already seen more than a
hundred thousand dollars in donations in
its first three weeks donors are
stepping up across North America in a
number of American and Canadian cities
the list is growing the project doesn't
take a penny for any of it I think that
crisis like the coronavirus crisis
brings out both the worst and the best
in people and I think we all have to
think for ourselves what side of
ourselves do we want to have brought out
we see the good that this is doing
literally every hour we gave them our
name and sort of hey we want to be part
of this and all of a sudden boom we have
donations already delivering to
hospitals fat lamp coziness as long-term
care homes are next and sustain the line
says they're happy to feed the idea to
others who want to help more essential
workers if you out there would like to
copy what we're doing contact me and
I'll help you set it up if you want to
do it for grocery store workers you want
to do it for paramedics go ahead and do
it Solomon says it's important for
people to understand the need isn't
going away anytime soon neither it seems
is the desire to give back
[Music]
coming up the healing power of music
[Music]
a choir of women physicians singing for
the superheroes
plus the kovat causes that have our
country superstars singing from home
[Music]
that is Canadian country legend Shania
Twain honoring health care workers with
a touching song from home she's among a
number of huge country stars joining
forces for a special five night concert
series this coming week on ET Canada
it's called Canada together in concert
in partnership with the CCM a foundation
anyone can donate and the money will go
to food banks Canada and the Unison
benevolent fund which provides
counseling and emergency relief services
to the Canadian music community it is
very chime times and I'm feeling very
lucky because I'm not sick concerned
about the health care givers the first
responders everybody that's putting
themselves out there
Canada together in concert starts
tomorrow night on ET Canada and if
doctors don't already do enough saving
lives we thought we'd leave you with
some who will also soothe your soul
[Music]
this is voices Rock medicine a
toronto-based choir of women physicians
it's their tribute to what they call the
superheroes of Canadian healthcare and
beyond take care of yourselves
[Music]